[Music]
there was a time not so long ago in
survival horror games were a pillar of
big budget development atmosphere with
key staying alive was difficult and
developers continually found new ways to
scare us but in recent years those major
franchises faded into the periphery
horror became niche survival stemmed
less from forethought and more from our
skills with a gun many games that did
fix tension became stagnant and lost
their audience triple-a horror games
forgot what made them so engrossing to
begin with and for all intents and
purposes the genre was a shadow of its
former self but now we have Resident
Evil 7 a game that's much more important
than you might think
[Music]
[Applause]
by now it's no secret the triple-eight
video game industry is a cautious animal
people play it safe and franchises
follow trend games cost millions to
produce so to make it worthwhile
publishers favor mass market appeal when
developers take creative chances it's a
welcomed anomaly nothing reflected us
better than the decline in triple-a
survival horror games in place of dread
and atmosphere veteran developers
gradually emphasized action that is
instead of making games based around
survival and Terror Studios created
action games with horror aesthetics in
2005 capcom started down this path with
Resident Evil 4 a game lauded as one of
the best in the medium the series fully
committed to bombast with Resident Evil
5 introducing cooperative play in the
frantic mercenaries mode it wasn't the
best in the series but it maintained
much of the tension and terror
established by its predecessor it would
seem that some hope remains
but then there was Resident Evil 6 and
what a monster it was
I still remember playing it for the
first time in 2012 trying to figure out
what happened during development to
produce such a lifeless corpse it was so
devoid of character so lacking in
confidence that I was left wondering and
Capcom completely lost its way as the
most iconic horror series declined the
genre wasn't without its few shining
moments the original Dead Rising
combined classic zombie movie tropes for
the bold time management system
emphasizing risk and weighted choices as
we battle the undead like Resident Evil
5 and 6 however Dead Rising lost sight
of its initial creativity what sequels
almost as mindless as a son dead
character in 2008 EA Redwood Shores
later known as visceral games released
dead space a game with clear nods -
Resident Evil 4 and Ridley Scott's alien
it's ironic that EA a publisher
notorious for microtransactions and
preorder deals was the company that
evolves survival horror when it needed
changed the most but like Resident Evil
and Dead Rising the Dead Space franchise
gradually became something else and
appeal to a wider demographic one that
valued immediate gratification over
intricate world building by the time
Dead Space 3 release the franchise had
evolved into a full-on
blockbuster third-person shooter
as triple-a horror faded away titles
such as alien isolation and the evil
within came as shouts from the shadows
almost as if their creators were
desperately trying to remind us that
there are still teams focused on
preserving the brilliance of survival
horror smaller independent teams did the
same the indie scene didn't have the
overhead of a Capcom or a visceral and
without a publisher mandating stringent
release schedules more compact studios
were free to craft atmospheres and
mechanics that didn't cater to focus
groups in game slots reviving Resident
Evil documentary series we explored how
indie developers kept the genre alive
even when Resident Evil was dying as the
most renowned survival horror name in
video games it influenced a generation
of skilled creators
despite its weaker recent titles but I
want to shift focus to another franchise
Silent Hill
once a mainstay in video games with
spin-offs and movie deals to boot the
series has faltered in recent years it's
widely acknowledged to have hit its peak
with Silent Hill 3 in 2003 and began its
descent with subsequent titles but
rather than just one continuous march
toward blockbuster action thrilled
Silent Hill just sort of fell into a
creative rut after Konami's internal
developer team silent finished its work
on the series with Silent Hill for the
room the property changed hands several
times bouncing between Batra games
climax studios double helix games and
WayForward technologies call an identity
crisis or a lack of solid direction but
Silent Hill eventually wore thin if
titles became artifacts of Horrors
golden years but at Gamescom 2014
something weird happened
Sonne took to the conference stage to
reveal PT a horror game had been teasing
for several weeks before the event in
Germany for the next few hours
PT was a mystery something elusive
players dissected the game flooded
message boards frantically searched
forum post mere minutes after its
announcement TT was all ready to stuff
of urban legend of course we now know PT
was an acronym for playable teaser and
that it was a demo for silent Hills
what's more development will be led by
none other than Hideo Kojima one of
videogames most celebrated our tours and
Guillermo del Toro a director with
similar clout in the world of film too
many people myself included Silent Hill
is more than just a game announcement it
was a turning point one of Horrors
biggest names was back with two
brilliant creators and seemingly
unlimited resources behind it in some
ways it was a faint light at the end of
a long tunnel sadly what follows is a
horror story of its own internal
friction between Kojima and publisher
Konami came to a head and after changes
to the company's board members in
business regimen Kojima went his own way
and he couldn't take silent hill's with
him
what's more Konami then began a campaign
to essentially eradicate PT from the
public conscience not just preventing
further downloads but in an
unprecedented move actually erasing the
title from Sony's servers if you hadn't
yet secured one of the scariest pieces
of digital entertainment to date you
were out of luck in its inexplicable
fervor after Kojima's departure Konami
grabbed a shovel dug a deep graves and
buried our best hope of a triple a
horror Renaissance and just weeks ago
Capcom brought it back to life where do
you think you're going
[Music]
the developer has been promising a
comeback for resident evil for a while
now for months before 7's release the
company made use of demos a lot PT
stressing the dark tone and measured
pace of its sequel with several
interactive teasers if you will they
foreshadowed a grim storyline and a
return to Resident Evil's horror roots
but these were brief slices of a much
larger experience and much of the
content we played in these demos wasn't
completely indicative of the final
product it was evident that Capcom was
taking things in a new direction with a
first-person perspective and a
dilapidated new setting in the Louisiana
bayou but just how far Capcom was
willing to distance itself from Resident
Evil 5 and 6 remain to be seen
the final product made all of that clear
Resident Evil 7 is a creepy tense
atmospheric game and survival is a key
element throughout it seems to
understand what may the series great to
begin with but also how to adapt those
tenets for modern audiences we manage
our inventories make efforts to think
three steps ahead and when the lights go
out and our plan comes crashing down it
can be downright terrifying
if you finish Resident Evil 7 by now
than you know
Capcom just released a legitimate
survival horror game this is a huge feel
because there's a very important thing
to remember here Resident Evil 5 and 6
are Capcom's two best-selling titles
ever despite their poor critical
reception these games made the company a
lot of money for Capcom to ditch most of
what define these titles it's something
that can't be overlooked on paper
Resident Evil 7 should not exist as we
know it now yet here it is and it's
fantastic Resident Evil 7 is undoubtedly
a return to form not just for the
franchise but survival horror games in
general
I think it also goes beyond that I think
Resident Evil 7 is more important than
we're giving it credit for as one of
Japan's most storied developers Capcom
has a lot riding on its portfolio and
Street Fighter 5 its major 2016 release
fell extremely short of the company's
target sales Capcom as we know it today
is not the company we used to recognize
in all likelihood it could have stayed
the path made another over-the-top
action game brimming with testosterone
and set pieces and raked in whatever
money it could but it did it it made a
game with limited supplies long
stretches of quiet and an overall
scarcity of enemies it made a game that
reminds us what made survival horror so
big and so engrossing to begin with in
many ways Resident Evil 7 is carrying
that torch dropped by Silent Hill its
following through on many of the hopes
we had for Kojima's cancelled project
Resident Evil 7 is a game unafraid of
risk it's a distinct experience that I'm
sure many people don't love but I do
think it will spark a new generation of
triple a survival horror and I think
it's a sign to game developers
everywhere that we the people who love
games and spend money on them are hungry
for bold ideas a few years ago I had all
but given up hope on Resident Evil but
here's hoping more developers upset my
expectations of the future
[Music]
hey everyone thanks so much for joining
us for our first ever episode of reboot
we're going to be publishing these every
other week here at Gamescom but we're
also going to be doing something a
little different in the off week jake
Decker and myself are going to get
together to read your YouTube comments
and your tweets anything about our past
episode anything you might want us to
look into in future episodes so again
thanks for joining us this week but in
the meantime until next Sunday
getting your tweet any YouTube comments
you might be featured on our show go
we'll see you then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you